now most of you probably know what i
mean by caloric restriction and if you
don't well you definitely will by the
end of this video
but what is less clear is the safety and
the impact of caloric restriction in
humans and if it could increase severity
or viral or bacterial infections
so hello and welcome to the chicken
science show where in this video i'll
introduce caloric restriction why people
think it could be beneficial and then
look at the latest analysis of a
two-year calorie restriction study done
in humans and see how it alters immune
signaling
so firstly what is caloric restriction
well the definition i like to use is
that calorie restriction is the chronic
reduction of total calorie intake
without malnutrition and this can range
from 20 to 40 percent
but as we'll see in this human data set
is apparent that the term can be used
more generally
and besides the amount
it's important to note that without
malnourishment is also important to
consider as calorie restriction doesn't
just mean let's just eat salad all day
but it's focusing on calorie count
whilst maintaining different food
components
and so calorie restriction has been
shown in many different model organisms
to extend lifespan and these effects
appear to get more modest the closer the
species are to humans
for example you see lifespan extension
and yeast of up to 10 times longer and
in mice around 15
and in recess monkeys is even more
moderate and here these studies
also show how food quality besides
quantity is so important
so how does calorie restriction achieve
these benefits in multiple organisms
well in terms of how it works i've
revisited a diagram that i was presented
during my master's which i think still
distills best all the information and
understanding about calorie restriction
it is the idea that high nutrients
through over or continuous eating dries
more signaling through normal biology
that over time accumulates protein lipid
or dna damage that causes aging
so remember this is a very simplified
overview it also prevents the activation
of pathways such as autophagy as it
activates proteins like mtor igf-1 grave
signaling pathways which repress ampk
and saturn activity and so repair and
protective pathways like autophagy
decline
moreover in yeast and worms combining
calorie restriction with mtor inhibitors
like rapamycin don't show an enhanced
effect suggesting that they're acting
through the same pathway
but that's just the theory what actually
happens in humans not mice and does
calorie restriction live up to the hype
and in my opinion these are important
questions to address since there has
been some concern given to calorie
restriction such as increased severity
to viral infections with impaired
immunity resulting from the fact that
building an immune response is energy
intensive and under severe calorie
restriction the body may put its
limiting energy resources elsewhere
another thing often disregarded in this
too is fertility reduced food intake is
an ever increasingly common cause of
amenorrhea when females skip a period
despite not being pregnant
and so anyway there are concerns of
long-term calorie restriction but what
can you do about it well you need to
look at data and lots of it
i say we've spoken about calories now to
talk about calorie
calorie is an acronym to an abbreviation
formed from the initial letters
comprehensive assessments of long-term
effects of reducing intake of energy
now i made a video on this back in 2019
which i think came from a 2015 paper
which feels like ages ago now but it was
after 24 months of a one-year calorie
restriction in young and middle-aged
non-obese men and women
what they saw at this time point was a
reduction in fasting insulin levels a
reduction in body temperature reduction
in resting energy expenditure and
oxidative stress and lower tnf alpha
circulating levels and so tnf alpha is a
marker of inflammation
but they did point out in the study that
nonetheless the small effects on bone
and occurrences of transient amenia
indicate that clinical monitoring is
advisable for non-obese individuals
practicing this degree of calorie
restriction
so the calorie study was trying to
assess the feasibility and safety of
calorie restriction and for that reason
much data was collected for different
analyses with different follow-up
studies done in different model
organisms to back up the biology
so this now brings me on to the recent
study where they analyzed human data
from the calorie study were over two
years humans achieved on average a 14
sustained calorie restriction so already
notably less than done in the model
organism studies
and to examine the impacts of the immune
system they looked at the thymus this is
where immune cells are made in the body
and aging of the thymus tends to precede
aging and other organs
compared with controls two years of
calorie restriction significantly
increased thymic mass and volume and
showed indicators that they were still
producing t cells
suggesting that
calorie restriction may even be
protective
they then looked at adipose tissue gene
expression
as study participants unsurprisingly
lost fat when they underwent calorie
restriction
and what they saw was that the calorie
restriction increased signaling in
mitochondrial biogenesis
and what i thought was interesting was
increased circadian rhythm signaling and
a reduction in inflammatory and
complement innate immune signaling
one gene they kind of plot from this
list is plague2g7
which decreased following calorie
restriction
the protein encoded by this gene is
involved in regulating inflammasome
activation
so they deleted the gene and mice to see
if it would mimic the effect of calorie
restriction in the mice
and while they saw the myospot protected
against high fat diet and used weight
gain and showed some signs of reduced
inflammatory signaling
most notably interleukin-1 beta and tnf
alpha
but not other common markers such as
interleukin-6
so with the human data and the mouse
validation studies the authors conclude
that calorie restriction in human
studies elicits anti-inflammatory
pathways that may improve adipose tissue
metabolism and that the calorie data
indicates that calorie restriction in
humans over two years doesn't decrease
immunological function
but one of my thoughts
well there is no doubt that this work
adds to the mechanistic underpinning
surrounding calorie restriction and its
beneficial effects
here they focus specifically on the
metabolism immune regulation and
inflammation connections by examining
the thymus and adipose tissue and
identify plaque to g7 as central to the
process
ultimately though it would be nice to
see further examinations from this trial
into the impact of reduced food intake
and reproductive health
it would also be interesting if they
could have shown how individual timeless
volumes changed and how that related to
the calorie restriction that they
followed since 14 was only the average
so more data collection is my personal
opinion but that's just my opinion let
me know what you think in the comments
i hope you've learned something in this
video thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening
you